[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
and this is a cosmic queries edition on
the
birth life and death of stars
who didn't know we know know all about
them did you
and who do i have is my co-host today
nagin facade nagin welcome back
star talk oh my gosh i'm so excited
about today's
topic i don't understand any of it well
you're in the right place at the right
time and you you're a comedian and
you're host of
fake the nation which i was recently a
guest on i was delighted
neil you were so great uh people should
listen to that episode
and you're also author of the book how
to make white people laugh
now i'd laugh just reading that title
and that's the entire book is just the
title that's it
and there's no it's actually just a
notebook where you can write your own
thoughts i don't know if they're like
the laugh police no you're not white you
can't laugh at that
it's a thing so i i
as an astrophysicist have some
background in the birth life and death
of stars
it does not compare to who we brought in
as a special guest a friend and
colleague jackie faraday jackie
welcome hi hi all right
all right jackie like lives in the lives
of stars
and she knows where they come and where
they're going where they've been
and i finally got your full title here
jackie senior scientist
and senior education manager at the
american museum of natural history
and you're also a part of our department
of astrophysics
as an associate there and you're also an
astronomy professor for
outlier.org so what is that
yeah outlier.org is this company that
was started by
the co-founders of master class and they
yeah which you you did a master class
right i did a master class yeah yeah
they're good people all good people so
you know that they put like they put
production value
as very important in the course creation
but they also like they don't skim on
content
so they contacted me and a couple other
astronomers to put together an
introduction to astronomy class
that would bring all the things that you
need to know about the universe at the
101 level you know
yeah astro 101 excellent yeah excellent
but
critical to this though is that they
came to the hayden planetarium
before they even talked to me about this
because they loved our visualization
space there and so that is it and you
have access to data that helps inform
so many of our visualizations in the
shows that we produce so you're you're
like a key
cog in that turning wheel of bringing
the universe down to earth
that's a nice wave so jackie let me just
lead off with a question for you just to
get
so we're all on the same page and nagin
since she doesn't know anything
we got to make sure she joins the page
that you and i are on
all right if stars live millions and
billions of years
and we look up at the night sky and just
get a snapshot of them
what right do you have to possibly claim
that you know how they're born
yeah it's uh it's pretty offensive that
we we decide we know how they're born
that's just audacious it's like taking a
snapshot of negan saying again we know
when and where you were born and when
you're gonna die and where you're going
to die and but you just have a snapshot
of it
one moment it's like the worst
retroactive gender reveal party
well right so so the thing with stars
which i think is
it's really fascinating is sometimes we
project
human emotion onto them so we talk about
the life of stars
as if they live somehow and that they
die
and that this is sad but there's really
no life or death it's just sort of
morphing from one kind of thing into
another and this is what stars do
and when we look up at the nighttime sky
we look for signatures in the vast
numbers that we now know are out there
that
tell us that this one is recently
in the stellar form that we see it or
this one's heading out of looking like
the stars
as we know and love them and it's going
to start to look like something
a little bit different so we do know a
lot
we also know very little but we do know
a lot
that's a disclaimer we know so much but
really we don't know much at all but we
know so much
um this makes you sound a little bit
like a lawyer
and not a scientist when you say stuff
like that you know
you have to put a clause on everything
because you can't have people thinking
that we know
everything there that there is because
then there'd be no
reason for us to continually like say
they're so mysterious the cosmos are so
mysterious
and vera rubin actually i think she
famously said
something like we're like kindergartners
right now
humans that are looking up into the sky
and trying to figure stuff out
no one should say we're advanced when it
comes to like everything that we know
and understand there's so much to know
and understand and learn
but we do know quite a bit about stars
well you can't just blow by vera rubin
without a little bit of bio
so she was one of our more senior
members of our community died a few
years a couple of years ago
and she discovered dark matter in
galaxies
so that sort of brought dark matter home
in a way that was like whoa this stuff
is not just exotic at the edges of the
universe it's in our face
and and we just named a telescope after
her jackie right the
um that's right yep the the large
synoptic survey telescope
which no one wanted to pronounce and we
say it's time to just fix that up
and so now it's the very ruben telescope
she's one of our uh heroes
in our field so go on yeah yeah yeah and
i
actually overlapped with vera when i was
a postdoctoral fellow
the phase you get to when you have a phd
and you're in between like faculty
or whatever next stage you get into and
i was at the carnegie institution for
science
in washington dc and that's where vera
did
a significant amount of her career and
she was a
huge advocate for women in science i
mean
massive advocate for women in science so
she was
it was amazing to be in the same
department that she was
by the way jackie who among us hasn't
been at the carnegie institute for
science as a postdoctorate fellow
i'm just you know talking to the choir
here i mean
it's just a thing it's just a thing
although nagin did i hear jackie say
that
being a postdoc is what you are before
you have your faculties
is that should i say that
before you have you touch and and feel
you you get your post before you have
your faculties your faculties are still
being owned
uh so that so that's great so uh we saw
we solicited questions
from uh our uh uh patreon members i so
apparently we're playing hardball now
you want to get a question done
in on this you got to sort of get in the
in the patreon
circle so negan you collected them i
haven't seen them before i think jackie
knows the topic but i don't know that
she's seen them either
so we're hitting that at this cold so
let's do it okay you guys are
up for some treats here from cameron
bishop
we have this question my cosmic query is
about life and death
after this sorry my cosmic query is
about life
after the death of stars specifically
for any planets unfortunate enough to be
in orbit
how are their orbits affected and could
life prepare
in advance yeah
you're worried about the family yeah
i know the um the idea that you could
exist
around a star that once was and i
actually think about this question
a lot nowadays it for a number of
reasons
but we are finding planets
around dead stars around see there i go
again i just said that
we always project these emotions on
stars but stars that have morphed into
their new counterpart so
white dwarfs these end products of stars
like our sun or neutron stars which are
higher mass than our sun would be and
you can find
worlds around these things like planets
that have either
survived they've survived whatever this
thing
was that was like to have your star
basically
lose its ability to be a nice core
hydrogen burning thing that provides you
nice sunshine and light
and it fades into this other other phase
so so planets can survive this
so we should talk about our own solar
system because we have
eight worlds planets
that we call in our solar system pluto's
out there as a dwarf planet
neil i know that's your favorite um
topic
[Laughter]
you know when our son starts to lose its
hydrogen and
burn out it's going to expand
and it's going to absorb the inner solar
system mercury venus
earth probably and maybe out to mars is
going to get engulfed
in the sun this sounds like a spin-off
series to the biggest
loser like a really
galaxy-wide spin-off series yeah
yeah yeah so jackie what you're saying
is in
death or in its transition to
not fusing hydrogen in the core uh it
will
eat its children that's what you're
saying you could say it like that i
think
that as long as we're going to
anthropomorphize right it dies
and right while it's dying it eats and
vaporizes its children
yeah yep and there is evidence at least
some observational evidence that this
does happen
that planets do get gobbled up during
this process there's
objects that we look at the white dwarfs
that we're white dwarfs as these evolved
states of stars like our sun
after they've run out of their hydrogen
um they
we've found they've got signatures of
basically
pulling in the last of this material
that might have come from a rocky world
like the earth
and so we do see signatures of that
planet
on the white dwarf it's a really cool
new thing inside
you're saying it's like it you're saying
it's like it's got food on its lips that
it didn't wipe away
it still has evidence of eating of
eating the planet
still in its mouth nice yes it's like a
lot like my toddler
all day long you know exactly what
they've been eating all day the ice
cream drip
the the candy cane right all right by
the way i just want to point out are we
uh
are we allowed to say white dwarfs i
just want to make sure we don't get
canceled here
yeah we're the black dwarf i think we
can say that
you think we can say that all right yeah
right yeah
but white dwarfs so planets around stars
that have evolved is
a thing i don't think you want to live
around it necessarily oh but a cool
thing
in our own solar system when it does
happen
that our sun ends up doing its thing and
bloating out eugene what did you call it
the um
the biggest loser aspect yeah a spin-off
series of the biggest loser
so when that happens it's gonna get
hotter
farther away from earth so pluto might
thaw down and be an interesting world
to look out uh at that stage
just i'm moving to pluto don't don't
travel
that ain't happen that ain't happening
i'm just saying i'm the same too
all right so what it means jackie is
that if we figure out how to
as a species outlive the sun we need to
find another star system to travel to
and i would hope in five billion years
we have enough space travel to enable
that
well you know we could maybe stay in our
own solar system neil but we'd have to
stay within because we've got a lot of
interesting planetary bodies outside of
the planets there's the moons in the
outer solar system that are intriguing
so we planted hop our way away from the
sun
as the sun is dying we keep thinking
about our own solar system
before we decide like let's kick it from
this side of the
you know orion armed galaxy and head out
okay
all right just to suggest it all right
keep it coming
again all right from ben sellers um he
writes
neil and others have said the beautiful
words that we are all made of stardust
by the way ben if you really mean it you
should get the tattoo
okay he writes atoms forged within stars
that later spread
through the universe after star dies but
how do we know that the atoms in our
bodies are from stars
is there a stoller bar code on mine uh
nitrogen atoms
a stellar zip code for my oxygen
couldn't these elements have been
generated from in the big bang or during
other processes yeah jackie what's up
yeah i love this question there is
something
that uh is kind of new into pop culture
or even pop science culture i would say
it's called the astronomers periodic
table
have you seen this neil no i haven't i
haven't it's really cool
so an astronomer named jennifer johnson
at ohio state
was getting so frustrated with
this concept that gets thrown around
that all heavier elements
formed through uh supernovas
so that you need supernovas that are to
form anything that's heavier than
hydrogen i can say
so um you know hydrogen helium we think
come from the big bang that that that
one i hope
ben wasn't necessarily disputing it's
the higher elements and you get some
lithium
from the big bang too but it takes
higher
level explosions to get the rest of the
stuff and jennifer johnson is getting
frustrated with it so she created
on a bar napkin one day this
this diagram of the periodic table
as shown through what processes
developed
those elements and then it got turned
into a graphic that gets used
out so i suggest anyone look this up
because it's an awesome beautiful
graphic if you want to know
where gold comes from where astronomers
think gold comes from
or silver or copper you have to look at
this diagram
it will show you what we think the
physical process was
that led to that element emerging onto
your periodic table
so jackie you're saying when i was in
high school and my chemistry teacher
said uh here all these elements on the
periodic table and i asked them where
did they come from he said oh we dig
them out of the earth
um i was i was little i was unsatisfied
with that answer
it would be a few more years when i'd
learned that this stuff came from the
universe
if we had that periodic table next to
the regular one i would have been
totally satisfied from early on in life
what you're telling me we should use
this periodic table
in those exact kind of classes because
even in the
if i could get on a little soapbox about
new york state's curriculum
oh oh uh oh here come here
we have this amazing program at the
american museum of natural history it's
a master's program
that we teach teachers how to teach
science and they come out and become
earth science teachers and one of the
core
elements in the new york state
curriculum is
uh elements higher than iron on the
periodic table come from supernova
and i'm like no no no no we know more
now we should be able to say like
there's neutron neutron star mergers
there's the death of low mass stars
which ends up
producing quite a bit of the material
that makes up
all of us and then there's cosmic ray
fission
that you can see there's there's a
couple of processes and if you saw it on
the periodic table you might start to
feel a little bit more connected
to stellar processes to stars to the
kinds of stars that are out there
so i suggest looking at the the
astronomers periodic table
by the way i love it we're all connected
is what you're saying in more ways than
previously known
that's i like that yes i love by the way
as you say that
i love that this scientist drew started
drawing this periodic table on a bar
napkin which indicates she got drunk and
started making a new periodic table
where most people get drunk and just
draw penises on a bar napkin so
it's a little different it's just a
little different
yes or some people junk text people but
if you're
if you're a quality scientist you drunk
and invent new ways of understanding she
probably drunk
yeah she drunk texts and new elements is
what she's doing
i want to make sure that i qualify it
too though because i may have inserted
that anecdotal note i'm not
positive it was a bar no no no it was a
bar napkin it was a bar now
leave it it's good let that one stick
we got to take a quick break when we
come back more cosmic queries
with jackie faraday we're talking about
the birth life and death of stars
we're back cosmic queries i'm with my
co-host nagin farsad nageen
always good to have you on star trek oh
i love being sure thanks for having me
i want more of you on star talk so we
got to work that out totally and
this is cosmic queries always a popular
variant on
the star talk model and today the topic
is the birth life and death
of stars and we've got my friend and
colleague
jackie ferrati from the american museum
of natural history it's what she does is
what she breathes
she thinks about stars day and night
jackie
yeah right all right let's do this so
nageem give me some more questions okay
woody asks does a star becoming a black
hole count as
star death seems like more of an
evolution but if that's true and jupiter
is a failed star does that make stars
failed black holes oh
i know snapped he got real hot there
he got he got all philosophical on you
jackie i i
dig out of that one jackie there's a
couple of triggers in there for me
when it comes to words that one
as i'll start with the biggest one which
neil knows that my
my super expertise in astronomy is on
these things called
brown dwarfs so we talked about white
dwarfs
white dwarfs are stars that have evolved
off from like our kind of our sun's mass
ground dwarfs
are objects that exist in between stars
and planets now what people like to call
them
because of various reasons which i could
get into
is failed stars because they don't have
enough mass to get their core
hot enough so that they can burn have to
have a nuclear engine
like the sun does so they call them
failed stars but
does anybody want failure in the title
of what they are let's just all say no
right we don't
we don't advocate for them thank you
jackie
you're welcome yes i know they have
feelings too right okay
yeah there's more on this feeling thing
but
they are not failures in any way shape
or form
i i sometimes call them over excited
planets because that
you know the word planet everybody loves
and so that's nice but
jupiter is certainly not a failure
at what it is and i would not call it in
any way a failed star number one because
that would also imply
that it's a brown dwarf from some rules
that people are putting in and and
jupiter's not big enough you have to be
around 13 times the mass of
the of jupiter before you can actually
get
some heavy hydrogen burning and start
entering a category which we sometimes
call the boundary of brown dwarfs
so jupiter is totally good with where it
is and i'm sorry to pick on ben was it i
feel like i'm
woody woody woody i'm sorry woody this
feels like i'm picking on you but
sometimes it happens
and then as far as stars being failed
black holes well i mean
black holes aren't stars either black
holes are the evolved
take on stars and some stars will become
black holes
if they have a high enough mass
but most stars are not massive enough to
become that but
you got to be a really massive star and
those are actually the rarest kinds of
stars that we have
um high mass stars the ones that are
eight
and more 10 15 20 times the mass of our
sun
those are the ones that start entering a
territory where they may end up be
having enough mass to go supernova
and um and then become a black hole
those stars now would become black holes
so it's a different category
not to pick on woody too much but let's
not let's remove failure
from our thinking let's go positive well
we could also buy that token jackie we
could say that the sun
is a failed jupiter yeah if you wanted
to reverse the negativity we could
yeah let's do that just just to balance
it out over time and then we can
neutralize it in 10 years how about that
yeah if jupiter wanted to throw shade on
the sun
it would call the sun a failed jupiter
jackie is handing out participation
trophies basically to all of the stars
and planets i think that's what's
happening here
and to be explicit there if jupiter
eclipses the sun
for another civilization that's looking
at the discovery of planets then jupiter
is literally
throwing shade on the sun that's good
that's pretty good well done well done
yeah yeah all right so they gained keep
going okay
jesse de la rosa asks once a star has
entered its
death sequence how long do they take
also have there been any stars that have
come
back into life or have come back to life
i like that zombies yeah zombie stars
yeah
that's the thing neil you might remember
we were at a science coffee recently and
we were talking about
zombie but tell people what science
coffee is just so
it's not like you're studying coffee
right so once a week
in our department of astrophysics at
amnh we all get together
and we review the papers that have come
out over the week so
every day astronomers are posting
their peer-reviewed here it is this is
what
my result is it's gone through a process
where other experts in the field have
put their check mark on it
i'm putting it out in the literature for
everybody to reference to read
to think about to comment on to
contradict and so that happens every day
you probably get somewhere between
30 and 70 papers that'll come out i
would say 70 is a big day
but sometimes that does happen and so
at the end of the week hopefully all of
us have at least looked at some of them
and um we get together and we start
discussing like okay so
who says what and what do we think and
so that happens on fridays and
we used to do it all in person where we
would have coffee and cookies and it's
nice it's jovial
but we don't we do it on zoom now so we
should call it something else i don't
know what but
science zoom bc before covid
and then before good times yeah but
right so the the question is about i've
already i've already forgotten what it
was it was on
sorry i distracted you sorry yeah
how long does the death sequence take
and do they ever come back to life
right okay so the death sequence and
i think this is an interesting thing to
think about it really depends on your
mass
how massive you are so for low mass
stars
versus the highest mass stars it's going
to be totally different
values that i could give you for the
lowest mass stars that exist
which by the way they are the most
populous stars in the galaxy
they're everywhere and if you want to
know how good star formation is
at making a kind of star it's really
good at the lowest mass stars
but those the lifetimes of the lowest
mass
kinds of stars they actually live for
longer
than the age of the of the universe
right now
they can live for 100 billion years
which means
that every low-mass star that was ever
born
is still around it hasn't started its
death cycle
yeah i like that phrasing um high mass
stars
on the other end of it they they're they
live
wild and they die real fast
so they go very quickly through all of
their fuel
there's a good analogy here somewhere of
the kinds of people that might be low
mass stars versus
but i don't have to and
the highest mass stars are they only
live
for 100 million years the lowest mass
things like i said they'll go for 100
billion years
can you believe this this is insane so
they're everywhere and they're beacons
of the history of the galaxy and now
once they do start going through the
phase like our sun
for instance is about four and a half
billion years old
as by our metrics of measuring it and we
think
it's got enough hydrogen enough fuel to
go for another four and a half billion
years or so before
it it's out and it's a red giant and it
blows off
its outer layers and then the whole
chaos ensues in the solar system
but there'll be a lot happening in say a
billion years it's going to get
super hot in our area of the solar
system
because the hat the the sun is
losing a bit of mass it's got a nice
solar wind it's losing a bit of mass
temperatures getting a little bit hotter
and so because of that
um conditions will change in the solar
system it's not necessarily the death
cycle but you could say
it's it's the aging process it's the
aging process for stars
all right so so how much of a star's
life does it spend dying
but maybe that what fraction of its life
so you if i live
100 billion years now i'm ready to die
how quickly do i die so in astronomy we
define
your like you're solid you're a star
you're not dying
as the time that you spend um what we
call the main
sequence the main sequence the
time when you're stably burning hydrogen
and you've got a core that's nicely
balanced where the pressure that's
coming from the core is balanced by
gravity trying to contract you
so that's that's a stable situation
and that's what we technically call the
main sequence so you're referring to
astrophysically stable
as distinct from emotionally stable
the emotionally stable star you could
probably make a really good comic
out of like the stability strip for
stars there is an instability strip
you know there i'm not making this up
stars live on their main sequence
and when they start to go off they go on
an instability strip where they
are wobbling around they're unstable
because gravity
and the pressure coming from their cores
is trying to find a new balance
and because they need more sleep you
know
and they need to be hydrated it's like
they need to meet some of their basic
self-care needs
there it is all of that and so
i would agree i'm in a complete
agreement with this
even though i said i don't think we
should have more uh give emotions to
these but it's
it sometimes it helps they need they
need loving
environments they need to be in an area
where they feel good you don't want to
be in a highly irradiated area
that's not good for you that's very
unhealthy or in a place where the too
many other objects that could do a
gravitational
uh slingshot around you and mess with
your orbital stability that
that's bad too exactly do you want to
live so that some of this could be
um like urban life if you want to live
at the center of the galaxy that is not
a solid healthy place for most of us
let's just all be honest there's too
much radiation if someone is
training as someone who lives in
manhattan i take issue with that
characterization
i hear you that just means you're
irradiated and that's all that means a
radiation
so tell me about zombies now tell me
about zombies so that was the other half
of the question
yeah so can a star come back to life
after it's already passed through a um
it's evolved state
and so the answer to that is yes sort of
so it depends on what you mean by like
what stage it might be and the thing
that we were talking about
at science coffee was these zombie
neutron stars
so these evolved versions of stars so
they've already passed through like can
you become a star
again that question i don't have an
answer to
i don't think that that's an easy thing
to come back from you can get
stripped down so imagine yourself as a
star
and i'm going to give you a companion
that's going to be really close to you
and that companion is just going to
start yanking on all of your material
so that you're in a companion scenario
where
one object is pulling material from the
other getting bigger
one's getting bigger the other is
getting skinnier and so the bigger star
the star that's pulling material from
you will
eat you and become a really interesting
kind of
object which we think leads to
eventually it might lead to a supernova
explosion
but then that other object maybe you
strip it down to where it goes from
being a star
to being a brown dwarf where all of a
sudden the core of it
can't process material the same way it
can't get hot enough to burn like a star
so you shut it off you just shut off its
process
and then you can keep going and strip it
down to it's basically a planet
to it's like jupiter and it's it could
even go down all the way to some rocky
semblance of an object
so there is that that can happen uh and
then it's possible
that a companion or material that gets
dumped onto you
can trigger you to have a new sort of
sense
of an object so neutron stars might have
this with a companion
that triggers them back into life where
they start
pulsating or they get a bunch of
material that ends up looking like
they've come back to life they get
um they become bright once again
companions can do that for you no object
is going to naturally come
back into some sort of stellar state
though it needs to have some sort of
outside material or outside mechanism
that ends up contributing
so to be a zombie you need to have a
friend
yeah that's a good way of putting it
just to help you out of the grave that
this does not track with the way the
walking dead works by the way
i think it's an episode it's a way an
unwritten episode of this yeah it's like
a nice capsule episode
i like that let's let's send that idea
to them neil all right we gotta take
another break when we come back
the third and final segment of cosmic
queries the birth life and death of
stars
we're back star talk cosmic queries
edition the birth life and death of
stars
nagin farsad my co-host mcgee you're on
social media right
i am richard what's your you got a
twitter handle what do you what are you
going to i'm at uh at nagin farsad on
all of the things
and that's any genius yes all of the
social
literal any social media you can think
of that's what it is
and it's any g-i-n-f-a-r-s-a-d
no one was vying for that name
no i know would it be funny if i was
like nagin farsad 343
on twitter it's like dang
there's a lot of us neil there's there's
a lot of us no there's only one you i'm
certain
and jackie what's your social media
presence uh
i'm on twitter twitter and instagram
and my twitter is at jfahrity that one's
easy i feel like
is it that's my name you know yeah
f-a-h-e-r-t-y yeah
yeah thanks neil and then at instagram
it's at jferrity17
so there were 16 other jay faradays i
don't know if there was i just like the
number 17. so as soon as one is taken
and then i automatically just jumped to
17. i got you
17. twitter's just jay ferrity and
anybody on tick tock yet
no i'm not so it's just for the young
ends that's just for the evening i don't
like admitting
going to that so account today and it's
going to be called it
uh let's redo this at j parity 17
okay because i'm young there you go
all right so we have questions this is
our third and final segment and nagin
let's see how many we can squeeze in
go for it at par parker graham asks when
a star begins to die
and starts his expanding phase can that
phase be long enough for it to be
possible
for far-orbiting planets to become
inhabitable
and even possibly create new life
yeah so i guess jackie it's not does it
reach the right temperature but will
that last
long enough for biological evolution to
do its thing which we know takes time
yeah so i think that there's there's two
points to this number one
is that during the the death cycle
of stars i'll just start calling it that
what happens is the
habitable zone around the star
does start moving this is part of why
we're going to have such a problem
around the sun
in about a billion years because by that
time the habitable zone where liquid
water doesn't have a
liquid water is the definition of the
habitable zone where it can bubble on
the surface
and so unless you're in that habitable
zone water is going to be an issue
so for these giant stones liquid water
liquid water is going to be
liquid water is going to be an issue on
the surface i should say too
that's very important because you can
have water
deep down under a crust of ice or
something you can you can have water
but liquid water bubbling on the surface
is one of our metrics
for defining like that might be a good
place to look for for life
so the habitable zone that area
moves around a lot as that star is
moving through the phase
and so how long you need for biological
life to show up
it has to get there somehow if your
world
already has an ocean so let's say in our
own solar system as an example
when our sun starts to bloat out
and some of the outer objects in our
solar system
there's awesome moons like enceladus and
europa
even pluto i know neil doesn't love
pluto
discussions at some level when it's
talking about it as a planet but that's
why i like to call things worlds
the habitable zone will start stretching
away from our sun
and they're already created objects
which may already have
a lot of the ingredients that you need
for organic life and so
i would i would not count it out as
impossible
but you do need some of the ingredients
there already
so the prescription is have something
there
be ready and maybe the habitable zone
will show up at your door
and you'll melt down and life could
emerge
fluently right yeah i like it all right
keep it coming mcgee okay
uh jared sims says uh hello dr tyson dr
faraday and of course the hilarious
nagin i included that part because
there's a compliment to me
in there um jared asked
what would happen favorite comedian ever
in the whole universe yes
that was in parentheses um what would
happen
if you could split a star right in half
would it come back together from gravity
and other binding forces or is there a
sufficient distance where they would be
two separate pieces lifespan question
mark
wow this sounds like a science fiction
something that the death star
weapon from star wars might want to try
to do i'm
done killing planets now let's cut a
star in half yeah
yeah yeah i will say a lot of these
questions are
are a little dark and a little dangerous
like i don't know what the
what people were thinking when they were
submitting them but there's definitely a
little bit of darkness here
uh could you split it like take a knife
like some knife and split it down the
middle
uh just a laser just laser cut the thing
in half and then what happens next
my immediate reaction to that is
absolutely not but um that's in part
because you'd have to be so sw
this is so science fiction because you'd
have to be so swift
and in order to figure out how to get
certain physical properties to not
immediately react
so that you could get a scissor through
it i mean a better
answer maybe is to a question that this
person isn't asking but i want to
answer and i think it does help here is
um when you hit one star with another
star what happens because that starts
with two halves
and number one how often does it happen
and that answer is
the stars don't collide very often but
it can happen
they swirl around each other because
gravity is something that's not that
interested in seeing the two
objects smash into each other they have
to overcome that then when they do
they can coalesce into a new thing
to get two halves uh is
very science fiction in my in my
quick reaction but i'm imagining but
let's but if it is science fiction and
you have these big old
hands let's say it grabs two sides of
the star and pulls it apart
there's a distance you could pull them
apart where i think
they would just coalesce into two
separate stars each with half
the mass that the previous one had right
so but i think
you end up with a contact binary
scenario
yes you could because we do have contact
binaries where two stars
end up sharing the same amount of
material that's orbiting between them
they're very dangerous and ultimately
when you have two stars that are
coalescing they do go through a period
where they're kind of evolving
as two separate cores into a solid core
so i'm just thinking how you reverse
that process
you'd have to pull those two stars so
yeah the answer to that one is yes there
is a distance
which if you could rapidly separate them
and pull them apart
where you're good and you will have two
smaller
objects that is that is possible so if
we were infinitely powerful
or we were the programmers of this
simulation in which we all live
and there's one star that has just way
too much mass and there's some needy
planets out there
you could have the power to just pluck
off uh
material and just put it where you want
it and scatter the stars
so one star can become ten well there is
there's definitely enough mass in some
stars to pluck out
hundreds of stars where there's still
stars they're still stable
objects and so that is possible but
you'd have to redistribute the material
uh i'm thinking of it like as a play-doh
like you'd have to make sure that the
outer core and the inner core because
there's
plus it's very socialist and we can't
have that
[Laughter]
[Music]
you have too much math but i love the
idea that jared sees the stars
kind of like our senate uh just split in
half down the middle
but i just want to say jared the stars
are not that partisan and if they are
kamala harris will come in and be the
tie breaking star
break that out um another question
all right yeah let's do it robert weaver
another dark one
okay robert river weaver asked what
would happen if the nearest star to us
blew up oh i like this question
um so i'm not sure which star they mean
because
sometimes they might mean our sun do
they mean our sun
this is that's that that would be an a
end game scenario for us here on earth
clearly
uh because that's our that's our life
force so
if the closest star to us which is the
sun blows up
um blows up we're we're goners
ball game over okay ball game over 100
yeah uh the next closest one
to us this is always a fun pop quiz is
a triple system actually there's three
stars in that system
none of them are actually going to go
supernova if any of them did we'd still
be in severe danger because it's
actually not that far away from us
the closest star to us is our
oort cloud the like surrounding area of
our solar system
stretches a third of the way out to that
system
so we're already pretty close to it when
it comes to like our extended family of
the solar system
so the nearby vicinity what i call the
spitting distance
area around our solar neighborhood like
the suburbs
of our solar neighborhood suburbs
well we're in the suburbs of the galaxy
that's true
oh gosh okay yeah we're definitely in
the suburbs of the galaxy
but if any of the like 100 hundred parts
said 300 light years stars
go supernova it's it's gonna be a and
once they get far enough away
it's not that bad i don't know the exact
distance
where we start to say like we've got a
severe problem here
but it'd certainly be something that we
could observe in a major way
and it would and i guess if it's if it's
the office century system
it would be visible in broad daylight
right i mean yeah
yeah yeah it would be like so and and
fortunately we know what that would be
if it happened
uh and we don't have to worry about
whether the kings will die
or whether to be a change in
the kings who are the kings neil that's
what i'm saying they're not anymore you
know but
yeah today the change of emperors you
know a new star in the sky that
something different is going to happen
yeah no none of that is an issue but
like is it is something pelting us in
the face
like if one of those star like it or
it's just
it's dark or what like i don't know well
when when the supernova when a supernova
occurs
it uh blows off highly energetic highly
energetic particles
in um in multiple directions and if we
so um a supernova that went off nearby
have um
one that i could use as a great example
is one that happened in the year 1987.
i think we were all alive yes it's the
one that we
saw happen in 1987 right
we saw it happen and that actually
happened half a million years ago
yeah something like that yeah right
exactly it's it's a far away object and
in 1987
i think it um there was an operator
at las companus observatory which was
one of the first to see it i believe
but it was a notice thing it was like oh
this thing got bright and then
the um they detected
they actually detected the earth got hit
by a couple of highly energetic
particles called
these neutrinos hit the earth and were
detected and we collected like
you know it was like 15 of them but we
did get hit with them but that thing
is so far yes and you do not want to get
slammed by the radiation that comes from
a supernova so as much distance as you
can put between yourself and that if
you're a habitable world
then keep that distance if you're
something else though there are things
that probably
want the supernova to go off because the
supernova when it goes off it's actually
enriching the area around it
it's dumping all this material right
that comes from
that massive star that was churning away
at all this nice
higher mass elements and it dumps them
out into the area
enriching giving feedback to the galaxy
and so
next generations of stars really benefit
from supernovas going off
so so there are there our frenemy
they can kill us but really we like them
it's um
well we don't we don't know if the
supernova went off that
triggered our own solar system being
formed well our sun being formed with
blood to our solar system being formed
but start you know supernovas going off
will trigger
star formation in the galaxy so it is a
good thing but once you're alive
you want to stay away from them you
sound like
we have the option to run away keep your
distance
right well i think if you're going to
find a new star to live around
you know look around make sure you don't
have any
super giants around that look like
they're going to be going supernova
anytime soon so that should go into your
like you know
when you go on zillow and it's the real
estate map yeah
very cool yeah like don't pick an area
with a super like a giant if you see a
star that's got a really low real estate
yeah that's such an amazing star like
look a little closer i bet it's got a
super giant around it but
it's like right next to it it's like
buying a house next to a friend like
buying a house next to a frat house or
something you don't want to do that
right so negan we have time to like if
if jackie is good at this
we're going to send three lightning
round questions to her let's try it okay
go
here we go john david newman on average
are the stars we observe
furthest away from us older bigger and
shorter live than the stars that we see
closer to us
and what's the shortest and longest
living star we've found
go gosh that's so much um so the closest
stars to us
should not be a unique sampling in the
galaxy because they
we should not be in a unique place in
the galaxy we have both young stars that
are nearby and old stars that are nearby
so we do get both the youngest stars
that are near us are on the order of
um depends on what you mean by near but
like let's go to 300 light years away
then you start getting things that are
like 2 million years old there's 3
million years old but we've also got
stars sweeping in that are like
10 billion years old that are near us
and so that's all
what i would call spitting distance away
at like let's just say
a hundred light years or so away from
the sun
i feel like i answered that okay yeah
but
i that was a little long for a sound
bite let's see if we can make it even
shorter go next one nagin
james uh senior asks what starts the
gravitational pull that brings the
elements together to form a star
i'm guessing that in a nebula there is
an abundance of the correct ingredients
to form a star but how did stars form
before there were any nebulas
yeah first stars are the best stars in
some ways and that was a bunch of
hydrogen coming together
pull the hydrogen together because
gravity is your
friend and gravity pulled the hydrogen
together and the first stars were mostly
hydrogen they were unstable and they
blew up
big time right but you speak you're
speaking like gravity is something
separate from the hydrogen the hydrogen
atoms have gravity yeah right and you
get enough of them
pulls them together they'll have a
collective gravity so it's the mutual
gravitational attraction
not like gravity is just something
hanging around or it might be how about
dark matter isn't dark matter of gravity
minding its own business i think we
should be honest too neil we are
gravity is very confusing gravity is not
exactly the easiest thing
for us as scientists to understand so
many mixed signals
i know well what transports
it what's it's what's its particle how
does gravity work
this is that's why again that's why we
go to the bar
yeah you get some good conversations
yeah it bought me a drink but then it
didn't really want to talk to me
what
so we've got to end it there but great
jackie thanks for coming back on star
talk yeah it's always good to see you i
mean i see you in the offices and during
uh science coffee and it's great to have
you part of this star talk
uh enterprise and and nagin always good
to have you
and your kids doing well you they're
grandma grandma taking care of him now
oh yeah they're getting they're doing
their back breaking work of running
after a toddler
okay so that means it's not as fun with
them running into your
zoom screen they've managed to keep her
at bay
all right so this has been star talk
cosmic queries i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal
astrophysicist as always beating you to
keep looking
you